oh you could see the pixels and the
squares the nothing phone is our
favorite budget Android phone but when
we got it it did really poorly in our
camera comparison but now that it's been
a while and it's gotten software updates
it should be a lot better now people say
that the pixel 68 is the best budget
camera phone for the money that was also
updated and we also have the iPhone 14
so we're doing another Showdown to see
how they compare yep so max went out and
took a bunch of photos with all three of
these phones he set them up in this
timeline and I'm gonna be seeing them
for the first time and voting which is
which which is better so grab a piece of
paper and pen if you want to join along
with me here is the first shot it is a
selfie that is backlit what do you think
all right this one is definitely tough
um I kind of like the one on the left
however I'm seeing a little bit of
softness and a lot of warmth I'm gonna
choose the one on the right I really
like the detail and the colors balance
everything I'm going with that one that
one is the iPhone 14. last time we
tested the 13 this one has the same
camera as the 14 pro so this is a zoom
shot right here okay instantly the one
in the center just looks terrible
between the left and right they're both
pretty good oh what it looks like the
one I left is a little bit blown out and
I'm seeing more kind of detail less
sharpening I'm going with the right
that is the
hot now I also want you guys know that I
looked at all the photos rated them from
one if it's unusable to five shockingly
good I'll reveal my results at the end
here we have another Zoom shot oh my
goodness what in the world potato camera
okay never mind so not the left it's a
close one but I am seeing more detail in
the center especially in the texture
here and all these areas uh jeans
everything yep so Center yep oh no that
is hey there you go nothing I do not
know what happened with the pixel on
that one ouch this is zoomed in quite a
bit the crazy thing is the pixel
destroyed the iPhone 13 and zoomed last
time whoa this is a portrait shot that
is really cool and I'm amazed at the
level of detail here look at all the
texture every single bit
that's interesting I really like this
left one
that is the eye wow that looks good here
we have a portrait shot there's a lot of
differences that I was forced into doing
okay so right away on the left I really
dislike how strong the blur is behind it
it just looks really messy I don't like
it the one on the right it's not even
doing portrait so it's got to be the one
in the center especially since you have
this in the foreground looks really nice
I like the center
you pick slip pixel I thought you might
pick that one uh but I want to take a
photo of this and the pixel forces you
to crop when you're doing portraits I'm
still so annoyed by that so I literally
physically could not get the shot that
the other ones couldn't the iPhone was
too far I couldn't do it here we have an
indoor tough lighting portrait shot I
don't like the one in the center because
it's the Shadows are really really dark
and crushed the one on the right looks
really faded so I'm going with the left
I like the combination of everything the
best nice balance and that isn't I phone
here we have an ultra wide shot I
thought this building looked really cool
but I couldn't stand on the street to
take the picture so it had to be ultra
wide I think overall in terms of how
clean the photo is I'm gonna go with the
right I like that one it just overall
looks good
that is the iPhone here we have a
portrait shot where you have a lot of
depth all right right away I don't like
the right one because there's no way
this is blurred out right above her like
these two it's sharp so that fails
instantly the one on the left looks
amazing just every part about it looks
awesome
that is the iPhone I will say I was
surprised other than the loss of
contrast here how close the nothing is
an iPhone before it depends here we have
a crazy dynamic range shot instantly the
right I mean look at that it's the only
one that has the actual sunset colors
and it's not as blown out yeah and more
sharp and that is the iPhone the iPhone
used to the 13 sucked with dynamic range
that's really good compared to the pixel
all right we got a portrait shot a
really wide one here with a lot of
background all right so this one fails
because look yeah random portions aren't
blurred at all instant fail I think I'm
gonna go with the one on the right even
though her jacket is a little bit dark I
don't like how faded and brought up
everything is here as much I kind of
like the one on the right the best and
you chose the iPhone here's where
Angelica would probably disagree oh
shoot too bad we don't have her today it
just looks really flat in this one yeah
oh you could see the the pixels and the
squares this this 8-bit man oh that's
terrible so as you can tell this is an
ultra Zoom none of these actually have
telephoto cameras so they have to
digitally zoom in on yeah the main one
the right one I mean by far easily you
can tell us the best pixels that is the
pixel what did the nothing one now the
nothing phone is the only one that lets
you zoom in 20 times wow when you're
taking a photo I'll have a Angelica show
The Originals the pixel Zooms in seven
Apple limited only five times but
cropping these after just like you would
if you took a photo it turns out better
than the 20 times zoom on the nothing
now here is our first video
all right I already know the winner
okay uh there's no stabilization in the
center for whatever reason it's not
working at all
the left one works decently however it
is so Overexposed and flat the contrast
is gone so the one on the right is by
far the winner and the one on the right
is the pixel oh that's good now the
pixels did 1080p only the nothing in the
iPhone could blow it to 4K that might be
why the nothing had no stabilization but
I'm surprised pixels are meant to be
better video but that looks good yeah
here is a selfie okay so the one in the
center is way too underexposed I really
like the one on the left I feel like the
right is too flat in terms of the kind
of highlights and stuff and iPhone you
got the iPhone I'm surprised how all of
them did really good on the cutouts we
put our hoods on on purpose here we have
a macro shot only one of these
smartphones has a dedicated macro mode
but it doesn't actually zoom in that
much because the macro camera I got the
closest to and the others I had to crop
so between the left and the right it is
incredibly close but I'm gonna go with
the right the right one is the pixel the
nothing phone looks the worst even
though it's the only one where I had a
Mac remote kind of blurry yeah oh no way
what in the world I had to convince my
wife to let me use this photo wow
because she's like no I don't want that
posted online this looks like a light
gray jacket or goat energy looks like
she's crazy the how could the phone
think that this fur is like great I
don't know software because you have
white in the background snow and a black
jacket so definitely not the left the
center absolutely destroys it because
you could see the Highlight roll off and
skin tones and it's not flat like this
is all flat
the iPhone nailed cheese pixel the photo
I don't know what this is tripping the
nothing's just slightly worse but yeah
and we have another video this time you
have the regular camera 4K 30 on all of
them let's take a look okay now I'm
seeing in the center some weird uh Focus
hunting and really drastic changes in
exposure I don't like that I think I'm
gonna go with the one on the right even
though it's really close between the
left and right I think I like the right
better
you voted for it the iPhone but it's
surprising how close the pixel is I am
shocked the iPhone's way more expensive
here we have
Ultra wide all right tough lighting yeah
I'm seeing some issues already instantly
I don't like the left because it's soft
it's flat the Hat's blown out the
center's okay but the one on the right
has noticeably more sharpness and detail
everywhere I like it
iPhone yeah and it actually nailed the
white balance too here we have a
portrait shot with so many layers of
depth the one on the left instantly oh
my goodness look at how nice and sharp
contrast everything looks
once again the white balance too really
good this is a tough shot we have warm
indoor lighting we have the city behind
it okay so the one on the right is
underexposed it fails instantly I don't
like it uh between the left and the
middle is pretty close but if you look
like at the texture of this chair so
sharp and detailed here it looks really
good
phone I would have actually voted for
the nothing oh really but we have this
shot now we're shooting through glass it
was directly behind Noah I'm gonna go
with the center because I don't I don't
like how this is cool on the right it's
way too cool
bad job on the white balance the one in
the center just looks nice and contrasty
detailed compared to this kind of faded
look so center that is the iPhone I
don't know how it magically gets rid of
the reflections and minimizes it yeah
some kind of software Magic
here we have some tough lighting indoors
wow the one on the left looks just on a
whole nother level better than the other
two all the brights just stand out
everything's sharp the text of that sign
so that one is the iPhone I think it's
defusion working wow and the pixel over
here if you guys may have noticed these
dark lines every time I would take a
photo in this kind of lighting that's
stuck in the shot oh it's the it's the
LEDs it's that lighting and it messed
with it wow so it was really annoying
now we're getting into night mode here
I'm really curious if the pixel is going
to start destroying everything all right
so between the left and the right it's
really close the one in the center you
can just see so much motion blur and
weirdness it definitely gets
disqualified but I do like the
highlights on the left I think it does
the best with the highlights
pixel really good oh what do you think
there wow so it looks like there's no
night mode here there is so there is
there is night mode there is night mode
okay this is crazy even though the one
on the left is kind of brought up higher
I mean it might be just too bright I
don't know but the one on the right is
just so soft all the detail is gone so
I'm choosing the left yeah this was
Pitch Black yeah this was Pitch way
darker than what you see in the center
left and that is the iPhone I was
shocked when I saw this on the computer
here's another shot oh that's cool very
dark our kids after jiu jitsu dude this
reminds me of the three ninjas I told
them about three ninjas right before
that
okay the one on the left by far because
you could tell this is kind of dark no
detail this is all smudged motion blur
detail this is by far the most sharp
yeah the iPhone once again man we're
gonna see what happens here next shot oh
okay this is oh my goodness what the
heck okay that's out of there all of
these had night mode oh this is Portrait
it is Portrait that looks good it is a
portrait language not bad and I think
the detail is also yeah I'm choosing the
one in the center the right one has a
lot of little noise and stuff and
portrait mode did not work you chose the
pixel that's good the iPhone it said too
dark but nothing took the picture with
portrait mode but it was too dark that's
bad here is the next one mix lighting
here oh the one on the left wow that
looks really really good detail
everywhere the colors the skin tones
roll off everything and the jacket looks
natural where you can see artifacts
noise this one at least and the colors
didn't look anywhere near that it's like
blue the iPhone took another one it was
bright enough for portrait there now we
have nice this dark is your setup
basement scene very nice extremely dark
all right so I'm noticing on the right
blown out everywhere look at this oh
this is blown out more of this is
blowing out here this by far does the
best in terms of that and if you look
close to the texture of the table and
everywhere you could actually see the
detail and the texture I don't know
which one is which so let's see
it was too dark but in this case it
worked out really well this looks really
good here is a crazy lighting scene
really dark outside okay this is
interesting each phone decided to handle
it differently all right so the one on
the left it's really faded not much
contrast every little branch is here and
this one every branch is over sharpened
it looks kind of messy honestly and the
lights don't stand out honestly I kind
of like the one on the right because the
lights kind of stand out even though
it's a little underexposed this is just
too much going on so right I agree oh
that is the iPhone these ones were more
similar yeah portrait shot all right so
this is instant fail I have no words and
it's not a Miss Focus because it's not
focused on the back yeah now both of
these look pretty good however the one
in the center is really flat I love how
all the little lights kind of show off
without getting Overexposed like here so
I'm going with the right and there's
more detail pixel you chose the pixel
the iPhone messed up terrible somehow
terrible ultra white here oh
[Music]
so in reality all of them were way
darker than this so each phone had to
choose what it wanted to make the image
be well if I look closely I can tell
that these lights are blown out I can
tell that there's a lot of softness
lacking detail kind of smudged spread up
too much apparently yep the one of the
right fares pretty well but it also you
could see some smearing and all this
details so the one in the center has by
far the best detail and not getting
blown out and it looks realistic yeah so
that is like the nothing it did a good
job here we have a portrait shot a wider
one all right so the one on the left
it's really flat lacking detail the one
on the right you could see noise in your
face and everywhere here for some reason
I think the most clean photo is in the
center
that is the iPhone so a lot of these
portrait shots on the pixel I would have
to move back once again it's the only
one that limits you and it crops forces
you to crop yeah we have a selfie at
night
wow this is so blue
we had blue light from the front warm
lights from the back well instantly
terrible amount of noise and artifacts
here this one gets disqualified this one
actually does decently well but compared
to the middle this has the most clean
detail you can see your eyebrows beard
hairs everywhere your coat the center
the pixel pixel and we have a portrait
yeah same issue here so much noise that
it actually changes the color other than
that it was really good until I saw that
noise the one on the left still has some
noise the one in the center by far does
the best with having no noise at all
here a lot of sharp detail the lights
look good the Hat the fake yeah Center
that is the iPhone once again the pixel
forces you to crop these ones I cropped
after but they still turned out way
better and we have our last video this
is a nighttime one lots of noise on the
right it's really hard to choose between
the left and the center but I think I'm
gonna go with the left the left is the
iPhone so the nothing did quite a bit
better right it was so close it was
really close compared to the pixel and
now our last shot this is the only one
that was set on a tripod okay for
astrophotography modes okay so the one
on the right I can see a lot less detail
the one that left is by far the best I
think and I like how it's kind of more
contrasty brought up brighter
that is the iPhone and nothing is a bit
too dark now I will say the nothing for
the night mode usually it's like one
second it is crazy the iPhone a second
two seconds a lot of times the iPhone
actually took longer which is crazy
usually it's the fastest the pixel on
this tripod it was like two minutes and
handheld a lot of times it literally is
like five six seconds it's annoying but
the nothing forward if I can give them
one piece of advice make the my night
mode take two seconds out of one because
they'll have a lot more uh data that's
why they're kind of underexposed yep
yeah so uh there you guys go okay if you
guys voted let us know what you got how
many you chose for each one if you
didn't let us know what really surprised
you or what you think of the phones
Vadim is adding that up right now I had
Vadim didn't see any of these he had no
input we wanted to see how the pixel
with software updates and the nothing
with software updates compare and of
course the new iPhone 14 because last
time we tested out the 13
um I also have my own opinions here but
Vadim okay go ahead and show them
alrighty so for the pixel I had nine
for the nothing I had three 23 for the
iPhone
that is a big difference crazy so the
iPhone did even better than last time
yep and uh the nothing was still in last
place now a lot of the shots it was
actually pretty close it was yeah it was
that's why it was close with my shot I
looked at all the photos I radium one to
five five is shocking that's a cell
phone one is unusable
here's what I got
for the nothing phone I got 3.3 out of
5.
for the iPhone I got 3.8 out of five and
for the pixel I got three out of five b
because
um I didn't just want which one's the
best that's why the iPhone stole it away
yeah a lot of the pixel shots were noisy
in the night uh or not detailed for
portraits
um during the day yeah and it has the
oldest sensors so I actually got a bit
better for the nothing than the than the
actual pixel and none of these hit four
out of five 4.5 the flagships that I've
done this with they were like over four
out of five so here you guys go of
course the iPhone one but it is also 800
or 829 for the 5G fee they tack on yeah
compared to
350 or even as low as 330 in some
markets for the nothing huge price
difference you guys let us know your
thoughts click that Circle above to
subscribe if you guys want to pick up
one of these phones uh the iPhone or the
nothing check out the YouTube shopping
feature right over there and we will see
you in the next video
foreign